okay so Jacob and Esau are hostile
brothers there they're like Cain and
Abel except the mixture of Cain and Abel
and they're very different Esau was red
and covered with hair he was a hunter
and a man of the field so he's like your
basic jock right he's extroverted he's
outgoing he's really tough he's like
extraordinarily masculine he hunts and
he's a real favorite of his father and
so and and Jacob isn't he's a dweller in
tents and yeah right exactly exactly
exactly right and it says Isaac loved
Esau but Rebekah loved Jacob now that's
a problem right that that's a big
problem and that there's a Freudian
element to this is like this family is
now divided because one child is the
favorite of the mother and that's Jacob
and one child is the favorite of the
father and so Jacob is kind of a
mother's boy I guess to use an a rather
archaic phrase and certainly not as
admirable from his father's perspective
as Esau who's a tough guy who goes out
with a bow and arrow and like you know
wanders around in the plains and brings
animals home and and he's tough he's a
tough guy so and but but there's this
discord in the family because one parent
prefers one child and the other parent
prefers the other and it's obvious from
the story that the parents do not
communicate about this because they
really take sides and so there's a split
in the family and that's I think very
realistic because one of the things that
you do learn if you have a family and of
course most of you do but if you also
think about families is that there's
there's deep divisions within families
very very frequently that no one will
ever talk about and or even think about
often because it's too painful to think
about you know and Freud himself said
Freud was clearly his mother's favorite
and the family sacrificed a lot
including some of the potential
ambitions of the other children in order
to kind of put Sigmund Freud up on a
pedestal and advance his education and
it worked I mean you know he turned into
a great man but there was a cost to his
siblings and Freud himself said that
there was something about being the
favorite of the mother that gave a
person additional confidence throughout
their life and you know there's there
something to be said about that even
someone like Eric Erickson you know he
noted that very interested in child
development at that first bonding with
the mother was the it was the place
where trust was established maybe trust
even in the goodness of existence was
established and so anyways Jacob is
Rachel's favorite and he saw his Isaac's
favorite now he saw being extroverted
let's say is also a bit impulsive and
maybe he's not he's a man of action he's
not a forward thinker and but he's also
doing hard work and so you know he goes
out and he's hunting and he's worn out
and he comes home and he's faint with
hunger and Jacob is at home cooking he's
boiling up lentils red lentils and you
know Esau comes in from the hunt and
he's like half starved to death and he's
sitting there in the aroma of these red
lentils reaches him and he's exhausted
and and and he tells Jacob that he wants
some of this stew and Jacob who's being
a pain in the neck fundamentally they
basically says no there's a there's a
teasing thing going on here and and
won't give him any and and and there's
you have to imagine this because it's
not laid out explicitly in the story but
there's some dispute about whether Esau
gets to have lunch and Jacob finally
says well I'll give you some but you
have to you have to give me your
birthright and Esau you think he must
say something like you know well to hell
with it take it you know you son of a
bitch take it just give me some damn
stew it's something like that so that's
what happens but you know with these
archaic people once he made a statement
like that that was you were done that
was it and so Esau sells his birthright
and this turns out to be incredibly
significant benson who wrote biblical
commentary said oh there's a bit of a
twist to it so esau eats the red lentils
and then from then on his name is red
and you've got to use your imagine
nation abit I mean people are making fun
of him right that's why they're calling
him red I mean he's already red because
we established that but no one was
calling him red before this and so for
the rest of his life you know every time
he goes out amongst his friends and
family they call him red and sort of
snicker because he's the you know half
famished idiot who sold his birthright
for a bowl of lentils and so it's it's
not it's not that funny actually
and so Esau is not happy about this and
and it actually turns out that this so
what does it mean it means don't sell
the future for the desires of the
present and don't be casual about what
you have and then there's an archetypal
element to this too and Benson says
various have been the opinions what this
birthright was which Esau sold but the
most probable is that together with the
right of sacrificing so determining what
should be sacrificed and when and being
the priest of the family it included the
peculiar blessing promised to the seed
of Abraham that of being the progenitor
of the Messiah and the error of the
special promises of God respecting
Christ's Kingdom it was at least typical
of spiritual privileges those of the
firstborn that are written in heaven
well that's a lot harsher than meets the
eye to begin with and so there's a very
interesting deep moral story there which
is it's sort of Esau does the opposite
of a sacrifice it's the reverse right he
sacrifices the future for the present
and so that the story basically says the
way it's laid out across stories is that
if you're the sort of person that
sacrifices the future to the present
then that eradicate the possibility that
you will bring them the most noble being
into existence that's what it means and
you can again this is the psychological
significance of the biblical story so
that's a bad thing to do if you want to
realize your potential let's say you
don't do reverse sacrifices that's a
very bad idea
and so ESO really did himself in by
being too attached to the present
without a vision of the future so he's -
in the moment you know
and and he pays a heavy price for it I
mean he's the first of all he loses his
birthright and and his double
inheritance so there's a practical
consequence and then there's a spiritual
consequence and then he's well he's be
made a fool of by his brother Jacob
means supplanter by the way that's what
the name means and Jacob is always
trying to usurp Esau as we seed and so
Jacob gets one over on him and you know
that's not doesn't make an older brother
happy when a younger brother gets
something over on him that's for sure
and then he loses the opportunity to be
the progenitor of the Messiah which is
like people already didn't realize that
precisely but it seems to be you know
it's kind of rough that so